hello everyone can you hear me okay
thank you all for coming here today
and so yes my name is Sri Sri just to
introduce myself
and yes I'm working currently at Spotify
I just successfully finished my first
week yay and before that I was working
with Skyscanner up in Edinburgh in
Scotland and and that's whom all this
research has been done with and before
that I was here again in London and
working for a social network Capital
Markets defense industry but throughout
the experiences data has been core to
every job I've done and and who has
programming so it was inevitable that I
went into data science and so how many
of you here know what Skyscanner is
awesome this is really cool and I love
it every time I meet anyone in the yeah
Skyscanner we totally knew that
this video what's that and so this guy's
kind of put those of you don't know is a
travel search site and where you can get
great prices for your flights hotels or
car hires and and they have over 70
million users every single month and the
concept of multi-touch attribution is a
really important one for them because
they're very much an ecommerce industry
but I'll explain why it's important in a
second so just to give you an overview
first and we'll be going through what
multi-touch attribution is so if you
don't know don't worry about it and and
then some of the key challenges around
multi-touch attribution which is to do
with the training data and and then
we'll talk about the solution that's
been designed which is a simulated
training data environment and so most of
this talk is predominantly data science
heavy we won't be like looking into the
code and but it's getting you to think
about these concepts in a new
perspective so let's begin
so for those of you who would have seen
the hottest hour would know what a great
performance Gary Roman made of Winston
Churchill well deserving the Sears Oscar
for Best Actor his shiny new toy which
he seems to be really attached to and
now when we think about who in Gary's
life gets credit for his Oscar there are
a few ways to think about this so you
could say right let's give credit to the
last person who had something to do with
his win and the director or you could
say let's give his mum the credit after
all if it wasn't for her
he wouldn't exist she wouldn't exist and
or you could say well the dad certainly
had something to do with his existence
so you've got to give him some credit as
well
so if you want to keep the piece you
could just say let's just give everyone
even credit now but that doesn't
necessarily make us any smarter so now
we could say okay let's give the last
person a little more credit and the
first person less at this point we're
designing an algorithm but still quite
making up the rules here so instead what
we really want to aim for is this custom
values that for the various players
which is hopefully a true representation
of their contribution to the scenario
and this in effect is the attribution
problem and you'll see this in a few
different forms and across the
e-commerce industry and in other
situations like when it comes to Oscars
and but this is what the industry is
trying to achieve today and this is
again a storyline from segment IO who
did a great job of it so I highly
recommend you read their blog as well
and so where do we see the situation
really occur in e-commerce so when you
think of Netflix
a whole load of amazing content if
you're anything like me you can't go a
day without it so when we think about
all the various contents what kind of
content is really keeping users coming
back
is it the Netflix originals is it and
the BBC productions like Sherlock or
extraordinary Holmes or is it the more
cutting-edge stuff like Black Mirror who
would love that and so what kind of
content is it and or is it just the
classic and she was like friends which
people don't mind watching for like the
hundredth time so where should Netflix
really be investing to get more content
to keep you coming back so this again we
see a situation like this with Amazon
again tons of different products they
started off with the books and but now
they have music and video and the
popular shopping but even in shopping
you have different kinds of products you
have everyday products like groceries or
you have small tech and then you have
big-ticket items so which one gets you
coming back
is it the big-ticket item you buy really
what's bringing you back or is it the
feasibility of getting everyday small
products as well and that makes your
life easier and again and you see this
it's 45 as well whole lot of amazing
music but everyone's really different so
you see the music surface in few
different styles so it could be your
mood playlists or it could be discovery
playlist which is more tuned to your
taste are just the classics maybe you
just want to have a platform where you
could just go see what's popular in
which country classic chops that's it so
what kind of music is again making that
impact so in all these scenarios we're
seeing multiple players and we're trying
to figure out who gets how much credit
so now we see how this comes across in
the marketing space
and this is where the attention is of
the e-commerce industry significantly so
I've tailored this use Kies particularly
for Skyscanner but it's generalizable to
any e-commerce industry so think about
say you you're on a social network and
you see an ad for an article that comes
through which says the ten places the
Brits are bound to be this year and you
go okay
what is this okay let me go check it out
where are they bound to be and you're
just kind of exploring what's happening
there and you see maybe Budapest there
you go Budapest okay I didn't expect
them now you're just exploring the idea
no real intentions of travel or booking
now from there a few days after or a day
after you see again Budapest kind of
come up in different contexts and you go
now it looks like I see Budapest
everywhere okay let me go read this
other article about to do cool things in
Budapest this time it's not Skyscanner
article just an article aimed by a
blogger now as you're reading the blog
to the right you'll see ad which says
hey Skyscanner
remember us do you want to see where the
flights are the prices are to go to
Budapest maybe this weekend and you go
yeah well let me just explore it I've
never really considered the option then
a few days go by and you've been talking
to your friends about Budapest or your
family and and turns out this might
actually be fairly interesting so you
wanted to share that article you read a
few days ago but you don't quite
remember that company's name sky
something and so you go okay let's just
ask Google so ask Google 10 places Brits
are bound to be this year and
organically you get like a whole lot of
results in the top one of Skyscanner
and so you go to go take the leg share
it across spread the word okay now the
pods brewing so
you're actually thinking about Budapest
and a holiday it's all coming together
and it's been a really long winter and
you want to get away on a holiday be it
to Budapest or a time Sonny in place and
so at this point now you and your mates
have decided you definitely want to do
this and you just go right let's just go
to Google ask for cheap flights to be
the pass
see where it goes so you do that and
this time as you get the results at the
very top you get some results which they
add and one of it is Skyscanner
cheap flights to be the pest and you go
ah that's what those guys are I almost
forgot about them they were pretty
decent so let me just go and check it
out
so you come back one final trip to
finalize your prices and this time
you've heard of Skyscanner a good few
times so you just come there directly
and book your flight now this is a
multi-touch situation that in the
commerce industry so which of these
points gets the credit for that booking
so the industry norm is to give the last
one full credit now in this situation
since the last one was you directly
coming to Skyscanner when you look at
the financial reports that doesn't seem
quite right we need no marketing people
are just coming directly okay so the
rule they have tailored it a bit to say
give the last paid touch point the full
credit now this teaches us a little bit
more about the situation but not enough
what about the other three touch points
they get no credit whatsoever and the
industry is well aware that this is not
ideal what we ideally would like to see
is something more like this where the
credit is distributed amongst all
players and this is where we can
actually start strategizing and seeing
what's happening how much investment you
can stop making
various touch points however the
industry is still stuck at this because
we didn't have the computational power
or big data to enable us so now that we
have those what can we do about it so
now we come to designing a solution so
the first thing always to do when you
come to designing a solution is start
with the simplest thing so the simplest
thing would be to just give everyone
even credit or give them buy time decay
or custom rules however we know we can
do better so let's take that 70 plus
million users data study it understand
what's working for the users or not did
design a data driven attribution so now
when we come to the detailer of an
attribution we still have many choices
in the industry out there but some which
have really stood out our two methods
one is Markov chain attribution where
you basically study the various life
cycles of the user and put design that
into a probabilistic graph and now see I
remove channel 1 what is the loss or the
impact in terms of conversion and this
is the Markov chain attribution and then
there's a very compelling competitor
which is the Shapley value attribution
which is a game theory approach where
you say let me consider all the
different situations the channel has
been seen in just seenin we don't care
about the sequences and average out the
payoff it would receive in all those
scenarios so computationally it's seen
it would seem like Shapley value would
be easier to implement than Markov chain
however Shapley value does well up to
you like 10 to 15 channels after that
the payoffs per channel get really
exponentially complicated to compute so
Markov chain do initially
a bit more cumbersome to implement
Steel's really well now we have some
strong approaches both with its pros and
cons however we don't know still the
answer to the key question which is
which is the best method which is the
best method for the problem of
multi-touch as well as for Skyscanner in
particular so we have the data driven
approaches we have the rule-based
approaches everyone deserves a fair
chance at winning but we need a way to
tell which is the best solution so now
we have the methods ready to train
where's the training data so let's take
a step back and take a look at a typical
machine learning and problem say houses
in San Francisco houses in New York and
we have some attributes there about the
houses that don't quite giveaway which
city its indirectly and now we need to
design a classifier using a training
method to predict the label of the city
so clearly we have a goal we have a map
and we have a route that's going from
that from our current position to the
goal and hopefully it's the fastest one
so thinking about it from this
perspective when we take a look at
multi-touch attribution would see that
we have the multiple different
approaches we just discussed and when it
comes to where we stand we know that
because we have tons of user data now to
understand the user flows the marketing
channels the sequence of events
occurring and so on
however when we come to the goal we have
no estimates of the channel we don't
actually have the actual values so what
do we do with them we don't have the
actual values because those values are
hidden in our real world they are what
are known as latent variables
now latent variables we can't observe
directly but we can observe them through
byproducts so when you think about say
the value of your university degree or
courage or your help this is where and
we cannot observe it directly but we can
infer it by byproducts so for university
degree it could be the kind of job the
candidate gets or the kind of place they
live in or how much they earn and for
courage making a daring leap or getting
the courage to speak up or with health
and putting your body to the test to see
what you're capable of and your blood
pressure your fat levels and so on so
even mathematically we have such
variables and one such is a multi-player
payoffs so in this example of the Oscar
we don't know that the director should
be getting forty five percent credit or
the moment should be getting five these
are just estimates and similarly for the
marketing channels as well and as label
there these are hypothetical values and
so what we really rely on is the
knowledge of our field experts in this
case marketing experts in order to
understand what would be the payoffs for
the various channels and ideally what
would happen is that we would be able to
keep everything still change one
channels perspective and do an a/b test
but this if anyone has been working in
the marketing scene would know that is
really not possible and first of all
marketing is happening off your site and
on top of that it's a very dynamic
environment so business strategy is
actively changing and there are so many
variables out there that you don't
control reason why it becomes extremely
challenging to try and put and the real
value of these various champ
so that's why we really need our field
experts been working in this industry
for years and understand the value of
various channels through their
experience so we could say right
brilliant we have a gap let's plug in
our experts and now we have a
closed-form a problem that can be solved
however even with our experts presence
we wouldn't be able to say how much a
method is better or worse than another
it wouldn't be possible for them to say
ok it is 10% better or 1% better better
or 7.5 right so it's far too much owners
on the expert excuse me to try and think
of all the different variables that
could be potentially impacting the
situation and then make that decision
it's far too much onus on one expert
even or even a group of them so this is
where we've designed a solution of
simulated training data so what we do is
create a simulated marketing environment
where we take all these expectations
from our experts as well as the data to
capture and then we start simulating
different goals where we can start
training so to understand that a bit
better when it comes to the expert again
key expectations and the main one which
is the estimated goals so we can say
right marketing channel values let's put
that in and there are other assumptions
like say brand advertisement and adds
value but not immediately but over a
long term vendor now that is something
we again need to understand assumptions
like this from our experts and again we
can get the data to support that but
these are key factors we need to make
sure we incorporate into any paradigm
that we're creating and similarly we can
take the known data traits we see
in our Big Data and add that in so we
could say right distribution of the
various marketing touch points first
initially top-level let's make sure
that's alright and and these are the
results actually we had where the blue
one here is the real data and the orange
one is a simulated data I did have to
abstract out the access unfortunately
though I absolutely hate unlabeled
access and and then we have the
distribution of the various marketing
touch points so now that we got the
overall expectation set now let's go in
and understand what kind of
distributions do we see for these
various marketing touch points marketing
channels so do we see an alpha
distribution or a beta is it normal is
it negative binomial and we can do a bit
better rather than just see that's the
distribution we can actually tune it a
bit better to see how exactly that would
look like and then we go from a user's
perspective and say right now let's make
sure that the expectations on what you
see for the first touch point of the
second are set and and then finally
again from the channels perspective
let's make sure that the key metrics we
know of as of now such as session
conversions conversion rates all of
those expectations are as required from
the various channels perspectives so
these are the key perspectives we've
used to create the simulated marketing
environment and you could do the same
thing so now now that we have a
simulated environment we know what is
our environments where what kind of
features we have we know what is the
goal we're trying to aim for and we have
the various different approaches that we
can start working with to aim for the
goal and optimize this so we can start
comparing the different methods and once
we know which is the winning solution
start actually tuning it to make it more
accurate this again would be
exceptionally hard if you didn't have
and
an accurate way to measure this and
rather dependent purely on see an expert
so now and when it comes to the results
and again a the mock just another point
for the simulated marketing environment
we've designed this and tailored it
particularly for Skyscanner and and even
in doing so this approach is quite
unconventional so you'll see a lot of
researchers working on estimating latent
variables and this is not the
traditional approach taken however we
wanted a pragmatic approach with which
we can work and make better but our main
benefit what it's doing is taking all
the expectations we have in our in our
minds and putting it into code somewhere
we can and set the expectations evolve
it over time make it better and as we
get to know our reality more so this is
very much like as an MVP that we
improved on with a few iterations and as
we learn more about our reality we start
putting those expectations in so the
results for multi-touch attribution
again will be focused for Skyscanner
so with all the various methods now the
simulated approach we can see that the
best solution has a ninety percent
accuracy in estimating the simulated
marketing and channel values and here we
see the top results and the best method
a actually yes so our current best
industry approach is last touch
attribution and that's where it is at
the Third Point and our baseline is even
touch which is again just giving
whatever is seen the most highest
frequency more credit right and then our
best method is has been given a codename
Z and because it's proprietary and it
can't reveal them and however we see
that
even the best method is 10% better than
the baseline and what's really
interesting is also that this is the
first time we can see that even touch
which is our baseline is two point six
nine percent better than last touch
where the industry is up so this to me
was really interesting and if there's
anything I'd like you to take away from
this talk it would be this one slide the
ability to clearly measure and see where
the various methods down has been
exceptionally useful and and this has
really helped us to realize where the
various methods dan what's good for us
and how to actually make that more
accurate and and also that that's two
point six nine percent is your
compelling argument that you should be
moving more towards data-driven
solutions than two or other rule base
and and it's again only like two point
six nine percent better but that again
is fairly compelling and have you been
using the wrong rule even though we have
the choice have you been using their or
wrong rule as well
and what's really comforting to know is
that the current best data-driven method
is much better than the last touch
method we're not going for one percent
or two percent accuracy it's ten percent
so now you guys could ask me what if the
channel estimates are wrong simple as
that and maybe it's not meant to be X
but it's meant to be 100 times that or
maybe 1% of that what that so good
question and what we could do again is
leverage the simulated marketing
environment where we could put the best
solution along with his competitors
under the test so here we have the
ability to paint different scenarios now
that we put all the different variables
we know our key
so we design stress testing scenarios on
the three key teams one let's just
change the probability of the channel
ever being exposed to the user to the
probability of purchase maybe we've been
saying that the purchase order is ABC
with a having the highest conversion
rates whereas it's supposed to be CBA
so we can do that we can paint that
scenario added to the stress testing and
finally the one where we fluctuate
relative touch points so earlier I
mentioned how you have advertising where
brand advertising has an impractical
later date here we could say you know
what brand advertising doesn't have
impact at a later date it just is what
you see on that day and that's there
so let's paint that scenario and or that
the brand advertising doesn't have a
long enough tail and actually we think
it's a few days whereas its impact lasts
a few weeks or two a year
so we paint as different scenarios and
then put it to the test and and what we
see is as we see here so how to read
this job so if you're close to the go
most accurate you'd be here to the
center right here whereas if you're am
overestimating to the goal
you'd be to the right and if you're
under estimating to the goal it'd be to
the left and the scores here are the
average per channel and in the twenty
different scenarios and I've just shown
like the top five methods again we had
to censor the results and but the method
Z we just saw previously is the one in
green so when we see here what method is
winning the most and I've just put
little stars to make it easy to read in
most channels it's the green method
that's winning throughout but not in all
and where it's no winning it's not
winning by a very small margin
that's why overall still
it's the best solution to adapt to
change so this is where and we now have
a solution that is 90% accurate and the
best at adapting to change and now we
come to the power of applying this to
production so we've learned from a
simulated environment how to how to what
method to use to to design a solution
and what particular tunings as well that
would be most ideal and now we can apply
the same tunings with the same method in
reality in practice so for the
simulation stack and we've taken
Skyscanner data to understand the
attributes of the various channels and
users and so on and designed all those
with those expectations purely in Python
thanks to the N number of libraries we
have and to produce the simulated values
and for the production stack and we have
again Skyscanner data but all the entire
implementation has been done for the
bidding solution with the tunings all in
apache spark and absolutely love apache
spark it's made my life really easy and
I could do a whole talk on it and so now
we have the final results for
multi-touch attribution that the team
can start using and implementing it in
practice in order to test out life to
see what's happening and as we learn
more about our reality we start placing
those expectations in in the simulated
data and thank you in conclusion sorry
and so we've been able to make
understand the accuracy of different
approaches comparison comparison of
different approaches tunings of the
different solution stress testing the
solutions and ease of production and
this approach has been
really invaluable to us so thank you so
much here are all the links of the
content and the images and thank you to
my Skyscanner team that have made this
possible it's been really exciting to
work on this if any of you are
interested in the slides I have the link
right there feel free to and have a look
and let me know if you have any
questions and see ya thank you thank you
so much thank you for a presentation I
have a question do you have also like
real results because why I'm asking is
those 90% of gray or better better
results are only because of the
simulation and when I'm seeing like a
little bit hook in this that's you were
computing the same I don't know let's
say a conversion rate of each channels
but those channels acts differently when
you put like more traffic into it like
when you are struggling with saturation
of the channels so it's like it could be
a little bit tricky to deal with it so
if my question I do deal with yeah no
that's a very fair question and this is
why we also use the stress testing
scenarios to kind of simulate that but
you're right in that you can't really
expect the saturation level unless you
put it into practice
so that is what Skyscanner is actively
looking into now but as you can imagine
to understand the saturation levels and
you need to run the test for a long time
in order to get that feedback at least a
good few days so or even weeks so that's
where we created the stress testing
scenario in order to get a quick
feedback so we can actually start
shooting it a bit better and and then
once it's ready we're implementing it
now in production but now in we are
still in the process of testing it out
and validating it which could take a
while because it just can't be in one
test that you do and it's like all right
done it's it's a done deal
it's
gonna be taking a few good phases of it
to test it out and understand how and if
it's actually working and in that as you
might imagine it's not easy to run a
test in the marketing space so again
their challenges with that and we have a
really interesting approach to deal with
it so it's happening
however those results I wouldn't be
surprised if it didn't come out for like
a few months until we are conclusive
so that's actively happening so I would
say you should definitely watch out
these guys kind of engineering space on
medium they're very good with blogging
things out there and when the results
are out they would put it there so it'll
be really interesting to see what
happens
thank you great question thank you do
you have more questions thank you I've
been actually dealing with these things
as well and I was wondering how you have
whether you have thought about what to
do with interactions
I said you you couldn't get so if you
think about a journey of a customer to
conversion I mean in a deuce in the
ideal situation we would have all the
interactions with any channel but in
reality in particular was a big players
like Google and Facebook they don't
really want to give the data where did
you sort of try to go around that what
did you think about it that is a fair
question again and and it's the kind of
problems again anyone would see if
they're trying to understand the value
of say TV add value again because again
and we don't really have exposure to all
the touch points true so this is where
we introduce fair amount of
randomization however again we work with
the experts to understand where those
potential gaps are and put those
assumptions in and this is where we
wouldn't know and everything we need to
to get a complete picture and this is
why again for Skyscanner there are a lot
of users who don't sign on so we again
are base cookie cookie based
predominantly so understanding that
space again and needs elements of
randomization learning more what's gonna
happen
and as we get more expectations and
tested out light we put those
expectations back into simulated data to
make that solution stronger thank you
okay we probably have time for a few
more questions thank you this is not
it's more of a business question other
than a data science one how do you
manage to communicate these wonderful
results to the senior business
stakeholders in a convincing way are
they already sort of told to listen to
your do you have a secret to share with
us so very good question and it is a
core part of my job to make this
understandable so again if it hasn't
been comprehensible please do email me
and like let me know if you have any
tips or feedback and the team at
Skyscanner have been very good in their
data-driven approach in mentality and
they make a conscious effort to bridge
the gap not just from the tech side to
business but even business try to meet
you halfway
so stakeholders wise I've had some of
the best there and who try and
understand the gaps and really bridge
their understanding and what's also
really good is to understand what's
happening in the industry out there
because you could see that and even big
labels like Google and Facebook are
making their solutions and they're
moving towards this direction so that
kind of is compelling but it's also good
to know speaking to the industry out
there that everyone is uncertain which
is the best solution so they've been
very proactive and really take one of
the core values to be faithful with so
tested learn share those learnings and
go forward so that way it's been amazing
to even invest in this understand this
and all the senior leadership have been
behind it we thank you so much for a
wonderful talk let's give a big round of
applause to three
you